here's the lunatics of the view going
down a crazy conspiracy theory related
to all this
close to getting them but you know how
here's the thing Biden is wrong to have
done this let's find it let's find out
what this is first not again one of the
things that gets me crazy is before we
know it's already been spun a specific
way I don't want to see that that I want
to see
someone explained to me a how is
possible that after all this time nobody
knew this because to me if you're
missing classified information I don't
be laughing in my house if stuff is
missing
I know it's going to feel like apple
research to you does it feel like the
Republicans are behind it
it did originally but I'm sorry but not
not now because one of the things one of
the things he's saying is that you know
some of these some of the locations
where the docs may have been shipped in
the transition I may have gotten taken
and put but still
this will be
um I'm sure you'd be saying the exact
same thing if this was Donald Trump
right like if we were to just flash back
to August and September and find the uh
the clips of you guys talking about
Donald Trump and his classified doctor
oh it must be a Democrat talking point
and we should wait to see and it's a
plant and all that stuff
and joy joy who the Restylane has
obviously been injected directly in her
brain okay that's the filler interface
obviously like one of the one little
injection just went right into her brain
she thinks that the machine is somehow
defending Trump that the machine was
about to get Trump and then at the last
second they were like no we're gonna get
Biden
I they
[Music]